en tournée pour quelques dates Bilal
Hassani était censé se produire ce soir
à Metz dans une ancienne basilique
reconvertie en style culturelle mais si
certains ont soutenu la démarche
d'autres se sont offusqués que l'artiste
souvent critiqué pour son personnage
sulfureux puis se produire dans ces
ancien lieu saint je suis désolé la
porte de graphie est tout de même au
cœur du programme ah oui absolument sur
les réseaux sociaux des internautes ont
même menacé le chanteur et prévoit de se
rassembler devant l'ancienne église pour
protester contre sa venue alors face à
cette bague de menaces la production de
l'événements ainsi que l'entourage de
Bilal Hassani ont pris une décision
radicale c'est avec regret tristesse et
dépit que toutes les équipes ont décidé
d'annuler ce concert alors Bilal Hassani
annule sa représentation a-t-il eu
raison de céder aux menaces
alors
alors alors alors alors oui
c'est une preuve de faiblesse et puis le
problème c'est que ceux qui ont réclamé
l'annulation ce sont des associations
comme cocarde Lorraine Aurore à Lorraine
qui se sont constitués quand même après
la disparition de génération identitaire
c'est très gênant ce sont des
intégristes il aurait pas fallu céder
cyriles de ton avis à toi arrête de
parler des uns et des autres ton avis
c'est quoi il fallait maintenant les
autres il fallait maintenir le concert
de céder à personne et comme là comme tu
as fait comment Mario tu étais super
mais je trouvais que c'était un peu de
la provocation évidemment il ne vit que
par le buzz chanter dans une église si
c'est Mireille Mathieu ok mais si c'est
moi
avec mille Colombes
il a pas un style qui est respectueux en
plus c'est la semaine juste avant Pâques
et tout c'est une provocation et je
trouve pas que ce soit approprié et en
ce moment il y a déjà tellement de
divisions et de de et c'est toujours il
aurait pas fait dans une mosquée il
l'aurait pas fait dans une synagogue
donc voilà c'est toujours la même
histoire
cette déclaration
non moi je regrette
mais non non moi je regrette qu'il le
fasse pas parce que c'est un site
culturel ce n'est plus vous voyez la
plus grande boîte à New York c'est une
ancienne église aussi de Church donc ah
ouais ouais bien sûr
donc je vois pas pourquoi bon maintenant
de céder la pression je comprends que ça
pouvait porter tort à l'ordre public
parce que du coup ils avaient préparé
des prières de 15 minutes dans mon
Moyen-Âge pendant 15 minutes vous allez
faire une prière devant la salle de
concert Jean un chapelet comme ils
disent de réparation pour mépris pour la
religion excuse-moi je suis catholique
je suis catholique
manifester en faisant des prières que en
cassant des du flic excuse-moi
ta façon de parler tu es un peu
méprisant pour la reprise
je suis pas du tout une bénite de
je vais pas à la messe je voilà donc
mais là ta façon non je veux pas à la
messe moi je suis pas je suis catholique
voilà croyante mais pas pratiquant mais
franchement là ta petite phrase
une prière un chapeau de prière au
Moyen-Âge il voulait il voulait
protester en faisant des prières devant
l'église parce qu'ils étaient choqués je
ne vois rien de choquant là-dedans je
suis désolé quand on voit la violence
des manifestations en ce moment c'est
pas ça qu'ils veulent c'est énorme
ta façon de le dire d'abord alors je
répète je suis catholique baptisé en fin
de cœur on va y aller parce que il y a
un mec qui doit rentrer à 28 ah bon
d'accord donc voilà je trouve ça dommage
voilà
oublie ce que je t'ai dit tu m'as pas du
tout manqué
du coup ça m'a mis en confiance je la
ramène mais bon voilà c'est dommage
certaines blagues certaines caricatures
quand ça touche à la route et que à sa
touche des gens alors il faut pas y
aller il y a plein d'autres salles de
concert dans la région de Metz il aurait
pu faire un concert le problème c'est
pas qu'on veut pas qu'il fasse de
concert c'est que ça pose problème que
lui fasse un concert dans pourquoi lui
faire ailleurs
on l'a pas entendu les gars je disais je
pense que à partir du moment où ça
touche les religions et ça touche les
croyances et ça leur fait de la peine
alors il ne faut pas y aller comme pour
certains dessins comme pour certaines
blagues comme pour cette certaines
œuvres il aurait pu faire son concert
dans d'autres salles dans la région de
Metz donc voilà si ça gêne des personnes
qui le fasse dans une église qui le
fasse mais pour moi la religion c'est
sacré c'est intime il faut pas y toucher
si ça blesse des gens faut pas y aller
c'est le propre de l'art de choquer oui
mais Géraldine alors moi je suis très
très triste je trouve que c'est
dramatique que ce soit annulé mais en
revanche je suis pas du tout surprise je
pense que c'est obligé aujourd'hui avec
la pression malheureusement avec le
cyber-harcèlement avec les menaces
malheureusement il a été obligé
d'annuler il faut rappeler que c'est un
endroit où il y a plein de concerts il y
a eu Christophe Willem est-ce que j'ai
entendu ici un chanteur c'est une tortue
[Rires]
il avait pas dit qu'il était cuire donc
évidemment ça ne pose aucun problème il
y a eu un concert de Richard berger
aucun problème sur la sexualisation
alors dans un militantisme justement tu
viens de le dire on le savait pas ça
nous regarde pas
militant Bilal c'est un chanteur il a
repris à monter la France à
l'eurovisionnement
quand il a des Claudettes il fait du
buzz monsieur
80% de des gens qui nous regardent
d'homophobes excusez-moi je suis
d'accord avec
Daniel je suis d'accord avec toi
t'inquiète pas je suis d'accord avec toi
cette journée du 8 mars et Jésus
je veux dire c'est ma meuf elle fait ce
qu'elle veut
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon